welcome everyone to the podcast I have
no idea what thanks and tired and don't
want to be here but we're here in raw us
like that's the thing the Spirit is
willing but the flesh is spongy I want
to be here but like and Tiffany got sick
and I'm just like oh I might really I
was able to hear me this whole time
oh no we could area what you guys could
but the stream couldn't one yeah there
we go
I'll do a good story let us sell for
coming father
that is Joel from the Cape Joel man this
road is paused the prettiest man in the
world for it's super effective
he's a beautiful man we are your comic
book podcast and we are exhausted tired
yeah some of us do you have didn't have
a fun-filled weekend we went to a
wedding some of us we're filming a
documentary yeah man everyone has a baby
tired and sick alright guys so today
we're gonna talk about why missable
Ironman it's awesome and Rob wants to
explain to you why it's superior leads
into it he wants to give you the
verbatim reasons behind it on top of
that we're gonna discuss New York
comic-con and how awesome it was in the
weird part about everyone asking for
Faust thinking that he'd fly over from
the over the pond wait people were
asking for me oh yeah they were asking
for yeah
why is it faster they asked more for
this isn't even this is not even a joke
more from Maui Rob I think they just you
were robbed wise everyone was asking
where Faust was nobody that's where I
was now nobody asked yeah no one cared
Wow well yeah okay then that's fine like
as soon as we get down here I'm
uploading this podcast and then I'm
never gonna upload to explain
one cares no one cares about me holding
content hostage oh yeah if you guys want
to see my videos you can here if you
guys do want to catch Rob salla myself I
guess we'll make the announcement now
we've been approved for a panel at the
Rhode Island comic-con but haven't given
us a date or time yet
so yes it's November 6 through the 7th
they think the three-day thing is list
it's crazy so we're going to Rhode
Island Comicon I'm going salad I are I
mean know what Alaska you're like wow
Rhode Island I'm in the smallest state
ever wait wait okay I ran from one side
of the street to the other and more like
a territory yeah it's like it's like a
giant city that they just made a
statement stories but nothing happened
to Baltimore nothing
yeah it's exciting because the we three
went to Baltimore comic-con that was
cool we had really weird we have fun
afterwards the show is just a good show
you should go if you haven't been to
Baltimore comic-con right but as far as
stories go you know we met Aris and hung
out with him for a bit
how's it I mean like we open up our
Wolfman you know like that was kind of
fun I witnessed different people wanted
all we did without me
Rob met uh Mark Waid for the first time
hmm what hotels are we staying at right
here right now on the show on Priceline
I'm bringing over Iceland we don't know
what day's work I'm literally flying in
for the panel on is it so you know you
guys haven't booked anything yet cuz you
guys know that we're doing a show right
now you guys what should I get on my
hoagie do I want an aisle seat on the
plane you know or do I want you know
an exit row I don't know why you all out
there while we're at it up right okay
how many of you guys in the chat love
hoagies what are you doing know what I
got hoagies is that the names different
everywhere you go sometimes they're sub
sandwiches sometimes they're grinders oh
you get five individuals who are half
asleep and not want to start with
invincible Iron Man we're gonna start
with with cod you do Paul swear you were
doing it just fine
Robb's like what hotel we all say this
is by the way a realistic portrayal of
what it's like to hang out with Rob
we're like you know man I don't know I
think I might get a divorce I'm just I'm
really I'm getting I'm getting to the
point where I'm at my rope Rob's like
yeah but what drinks should we get Rob
is like that scene in the room where
we're mark and Johnny are talking to
each other and Johnny is talking about
like his marriage falling apart and
Marcos you don't think about moving into
a big place you know I'm getting money
that's not true literal example what you
just butt that make rub the Joey of this
group oh I love that we all know the
room so well you can just say he's the
Joey and be like mmm there's no Joey in
the room all right I haven't seen the
room but I know I know although that's
one of those movies where even if you
haven't seen everyone knows the lines
never knows about mark and Lisa yeah no
we'll do it we'll do a room thing one
day but not now let's go back to the
diccon discuss yeah the comic book
discussion so the room con when we all
went to the room con that was fine I
would go to a room con so Baltimore
comic I was cool you should tell each
eka there are some video that we did
about it yeah that's all I'm doing to do
New York Comic Con in the other hand was
epic like oh yeah I know it was crazy
speech was great the the you know the
show has it's been ten years the show
this is its tenth year doing New York
Comic Con it's my tenth year going to
New York Comic Con
and are you subtle no yeah right I mean
you know whatever kids go but like it's
starting 2006 and they've been hammering
out the details the last three years has
been identical like in the same setup
for the last three years artists alley
is in like an annex room which is
actually not a bad idea because it's
just it's basically just their own con
over there mmm
then there's this weird and weird system
this time though where you could walk in
one way then they would shuffle you out
of the building the outside building
like you're not allowed to wear your
shoes in your house like it's but it's
actually not a bad idea because I've
been stuck in there's this channel that
leads from Aris alley to the main hall
and they've always get the weirdest
boost there there's no try to promote
the Jerry Springer Show they were
calling Jerry Springer and they were
promoting the Larry Fillmore Wilmore
show whatever the hell I am and it was
hilarious that they chose that
particular host to try and get tickets
to because Larry film or whatever had
just been under fire from the internet
for having Bill Nighy on and basically
completely trashing him and the Mars
discovery and I was like the last thing
you want to do is basically call Bill
Nye an [ __ ] and then go to Comic Con
where he is a patron saint like Bill Nye
yeah Bale naw he has like yeah he is a
patron state of comic-con like it's Bill
Nye you know Bob Ross oh god Bob Ross I
wish she was still alive because she's
Bob Ross like like people are like over
oh I love your voice no I loved Bob
Bruce's voice like that guy's voice man
like I really feel like Bob Ross painted
Morgan Freeman into existence a couple
cool things and problems first off day
one seeing the Raptor roaming around
from Jurassic world roaming around
tall as all hell day to when entirely
blocks up an entire section of New York
comic-con not cool as hell they they
built this huge like Jurassic world
entryway for the
and they were blasting the Jurassic Park
theme from hidden speakers behind big 13
seconds of it but just the part that you
let matters and they don't fade away
then
do-do-do-do-do-do-do that's what you
want you don't want to be you nobody
walking through the doorways during with
the trail and like the the pterodactyl
solutely in a part you want the main and
and it let me tell you something
I like Jurassic Park I'm a fan I'm not
like a fanboy for a Jurassic Park but I
dig it and even I was like going through
those big R big archways with the main
John Williams theme and I'm like holy
crap this is kind of Awesome
he was pretty sweet to go with those
they had like an animatronic Raptor at
the entry which is cool because you
would see as you walked in and because
of traffic sued what it was a dude in a
raptor oh he was a dude in the suit and
it was a guy in there and he was like
doing any other crap I don't think he
got paid for that yeah it was it was
awesome like when he was running around
there's also a dude in an inflatable
Raptor suit one of those like one of
those uh one of those mascots were like
they're in the big air thing and he
looked as stupid and hilarious as it
does and the best one of the best
visuals from New York Comic Con is we
were sitting in the press room and we're
just like oh god like this is the day
and then Jack Sparrow comes charging
past us at full steam just running and
then this inflatable Raptor comes out of
the note I don't know we're chasing app
like this is the most surreal moment of
my existence right here welcome to New
York kids but it's like everyday but
they're like epic huge like you know
tens of thousands people Benny what were
some of the highlights what was it let's
let's hit LA for the first thing was the
first thing that happened was Dan my
editor in my channel we got invited to
go get vodka like who's the sink do you
want to coast like here yeah no it was
like do you want free vodka from HBO
we're like okay and they were like it's
gonna be for the show Silicon Valley and
I like why
season one and you're gonna give me free
vodka Hey look good enough right so
we're assuming this is like a nighttime
Thursday party think now it's 2 p.m. in
the afternoon free vodka at 2 p.m. in
the afternoon yeah we show up and we get
behind like they're walking through the
condo they're making a big scene about
the Silicon Valley guys being there and
they wanted us to walk behind them
during the scene so that we would be on
the camera so we're doing that the whole
way through and they shuffle us into a
panel and it turns out that the Silicon
Valley guys are crashing coming for girl
19's panel actually coming for girl 19th
panel yeah it was like so weird cuz you
walk in there and then you just see this
girl pink hair and like I know a girl
pink hair oh my god it's her
we didn't even know that she was gonna
have a panel that was kind of like a
left field thing for us no idea that day
she was gonna be there be she's gonna do
a signing or see that she was gonna have
a panel at all like that was kind of
surprising for me I don't know about
anybody else like was anybody else like
aware that that was gonna happen cuz I
don't know why either he's like oh good
I was surprised to hear that she was
there actually because she just gotten
back from I know maker studio sent her
to Asia pop Comic Con in Manila sorry
directly from there to New York or maybe
she had a connecting flight and they're
like you know what this works out
perfectly just go I mean the fact is
that with no with been exact IKAR was
once that was over we then step outside
and they're like free vodka for anybody
who's with us here go into this thing
and what they did was they put you in a
boot that was the size of like four
tables that was the entire free vodka
area but of course the line is now like
up the escalator for free vodka shots
now I will say I gotta say like while
they've all the Smirnoff thing was
pretty awesome that was not the drink of
the con the drink of the con was the was
the alternate 2015's Pepsi perfect from
the back home future oh we're back the
future had their own corner where they
were pointing the Oscar the October 21st
release of the re-release of back to
future on a and as such they create Lee
recreated the bar scene from cafe 80s
and anybody who
dressed as marty mcfly could get
themselves a newly created pepsi perfect
in the case they would go up to the bar
it would come out from this from the bar
and they and they would get to take it
out about that word cuz I didn't have a
best let me walk over to it that's how
it works and you and you could only get
it if you were dressed as money McFly or
I guess worked there but don't worry
because they are making 1500 and you
could buy one for $22 super limited yeah
let's do rail the conversation so we
could just go on your internet netquest
or your web so that was cool though and
that was cool we bombed the whole thing
and then Chris we leave and of course
she's popping up at a bunch of other
stuff and we're all like what the hell's
going on but the cooler part in my
opinion was the valium thing oh my god
so valiant with like Friday rolls around
and we team up with a valiant and and
they wanna they want to treat us to talk
about what we're gonna do with their
booth and what we're gonna do and I
think we just lost the twitch feed what
no I'm fine okay cool um so we go and
they treat us first up tell you right
now don't ever bring the weekly don't
ever bring me
let's just go mean Casals fine bring me
to a whiskey bar and tell me I can drink
as much whiskey as I want I think you
were much more put together than
Baltimore
I don't know happen to Baltimore right
you don't even remember what happened to
Baltimore but anyone who says they
remember both their take of alcohol to
food ratio so that it wouldn't be a bad
ratio this time around I know you were
getting drunk it's one o'clock in the
afternoon
yeah the thing I think you ate more than
New York this time so it helped out both
in bulk okay for the record bra all of
us been off for a week we pulled dinner
at Baltimore and we couldn't get into a
restaurant so they let us sit at the bar
so we all got like cocktails like girly
little fruity cocktails like it was
great we all had fruit there and I'm all
I'm old enough I don't give a crap about
looking like a man whatever I'll have an
umbrella it's cool those umbrellas are
awfully any drink that you have with
Walt with umbrellas is gonna be
delicious right so they're all sipping
theirs down and me not
like because we also ordered an
appetizer so I'm thinking we're gonna
get this soon
so I basically we had a really long day
and I'm just like take instead of water
basically yeah so I chug that whole
thing down I'd ordered a second one well
we still don't have our appetizer and
they're dropping the ball of tart we
have no food
we have no I mean table no table and so
I'm just drinking cocktails which for
anybody who drinks alcoholic drinks
normally that has more alcohol content
in it than a straight shot cuz they'll
put multiple shots in one of those
things right
so I'm chugging these down so by the
time we sit at the table I'm hammered
it's good to know that Benny is a happy
drunk and not like a violent yeah yeah
like he got it from the table twice to
go find the server and fail each time
like if I were the server I would have
been scarce as well where is she
yeah he was like super he's like all
right I'm gonna go find the server like
he staggers up for some reason we never
stopped like he staggers I didn't want
to stop him because I kind of wanted him
to find her because she was really bad
at her job so that's what happened to
Baltimore and I had a really bad
hangover the next day key bar which is
about like a few under comic-con like we
went to Baltimore for fun New York
Comicon I was there for business and
that meeting was supposed to be business
now once again there were now this time
it's free whiskey and the guy Josh she's
an awesome guy valiant is just supplying
us with whiskey before the food so I'm
just sitting there like okay okay all
right
and then I literally had to get to a
point where we're trying to discuss
business and they're like so do you want
to do more value books and I'm like yeah
how do like no more DC or marvel ninja
man they got a great business model ply
you with booze first and you'll be up
for anything so I'm sitting there I'm
like ow you know we'll do seven days a
week of valium whatever man flash
horrible you so I realized
doing sounds like so okay where's the
burgers I look like the guy
what's-his-name from the Popeye well ya
know the burger dude no thank you
so now I got Burt like slider burgers
here but now the drunk has already
started so I'm like charming and not
disgusting but it was hilarious cuz but
the same party heiress is there and
heiress like we're all talking business
with everyone and Eric's just picked
some random writer and he's just over
there talking to the writer this whole
time so we're all just drinking but
somehow and I remember this every time I
get into a conversation it'll be like a
legitimate conversation it would end and
then I'm just left free-floating like at
this point yeah yeah you would see like
these pockets of groups that are all
talking and he would show up be like hey
what do you guys do I'm from the
internet you can come
I'm from the internet I'll bring you
there well that was valued to make the
better situation even better like cuz
you took over like 10:30 didn't you sell
or you I mean when they said the party
was over we went home for the record the
party was supposed to go from like 8:00
to 9:00 and Napoleon and 30
yeah 11:00 11:30 we were like okay it's
time to stop and like a few of us left
my team left a couple the valley guys
were like we're going to bed
but no it's funny so like so Josh the
contact for Valene is the only one sober
the CEO of valiant is now Strunk with me
the CEO of valiant is bringing girls
over that apparently used to intern for
them yeah you should meet Betty and I'm
just thinking like worst time ever to
not wear my wedding ring I mean I didn't
do anything so we're fine no exactly
yeah there were no flows no funny
business
right now.i nothing happened but I'm
just most of these girls keep coming on
so now we're all drunk it's like 11:30
Sal's left it's me the CEO and like in
like the the one of the writers and a
colorist we're all just now we're just
drinking we're just not the business
part of the night is over now you just
got a bunch of guys drinking whiskey
freely
and so one of the colors is like we
should all go to a strip club is often
set in these situations usually said if
I wanted to mention this part because
this is how awesome valine is they don't
want you to get yourself in trouble cuz
we're all drunk and rolling yeah that's
a great idea and Josh is not drunk and
he's like tell you what I'm gonna bring
you guys down to a bar down the street
you'll get one more beer and everyone's
gonna disperse then it will go home so
that was Friday night
so then Saturday what is like wait that
was Friday we also I think we also went
to a convention at some point in the
drunken madness business-wise on Friday
I spoke to like so many people I got the
chat with DC Jason Inman he's awesome
great guys in DC did not win he did the
[ __ ] superhero or a comic book fan say
yeah video and is also the host of DC
all-access right Wow and he invited me
to a party on Saturday so I went to that
one but the way it was made out was more
exclusive than it turned out to be I'll
say that's sort of minute but so we did
all that stuff Friday Saturday rolls
around we're getting text messages from
valiant now I know sounds good to go cuz
he wasn't drinking so he's already guess
so I'm messin TV value at this point
they're texting me at 10 like rise and
shine we'll see you at the booth at
11:00 with the signing and I'm texting
them back like dude I'm so hungover we
can't make it in like that kid making
excuses why you couldn't go to school oh
I can't go today legitimately like I
can't get up and we all made in there
and they gave us like the world's the
game was breaks to eat for bagels they
were like this big little pizzas it was
amazing like Benny on his bed going why
is the room spinning he didn't sign up
for this oh no I didn't get that drunk I
always kept myself right below these
stupid drunk my editor got stupid drunk
so by the time we got back to the hotel
room like all night all's I hear is he's
in bed
he said something goes oh man the room
spinning he walks to the bathroom you
hear the sink turn on and he goes back
to bed two seconds oh man the room
spinning gets up once in the bathroom
maybe cuz magazine why'd you let me
drink I mean I let you do nothing those
free drinks you drink all you wanted
yeah he did we hung out with him a
little while was a lot of fun we're uh
yeah it was what is Stephanie saying
wrong with my regular what is her
version of a collection the chat yeah
I'm on the show right now I can't read
then stuff are new but yeah it was it
was a good it was a good time what we
did you you made it like you had no
problem getting but I was fine cuz for
me the way it the way a business drink
is everything I do alcoholic followed up
by one glass of water so the only
downside to my style of drinking for
business is I have to take a massive
leak at the end of the night goes right
through you it's true I know so what
ends up happening though it's Saturday
rolls around we're all walking around
making all kinds of meet and greets some
interesting ones some not interesting
ones some odd ones it was it was fun
deciding amazing I mean so that was now
I had so much fun with that yeah it was
it was great we uh you know the first of
all I was I my expectation for doing a
meet and greet at that the value booth
was just I think was going to be a base
by base I mean like a base like a
playground where it's like you touch it
and you're on base but no valley was
like no you get table space and chairs
and like yeah they and they printed up
little little like name cards with our
pictures on them so the people who so
that when people came up to buy comics
we could say no we're not actually here
to sell it's having quite a bit this
guy's like this guy came up to me cuz
I'm on the end and he is so do you write
this or what I'm like nah man I'm doing
this this this signing anything from the
internet and he's like leave I guess
just graduated art school yeah oh my god
and I might not don't talk to those guys
like really like there's a guy there's
an artist comes up Benny he's like he's
a guy just graduated from Jo ku Bert's
I'm really
in working for valiant here's what I've
gotten Betty's like dude don't tell me
man I don't let the guy along yeah it's
pretty good no well yeah that's such a
cruel thing yeah man you know actually
we just got a brand new book we go
looking for a new artist let me see your
portfolio oh just kidding up we did give
him a card and say hey but also check
out my channel though yeah exactly but
no is really nice and like you know fans
kept coming it was a steady stream of
people who were really excited to meet
that and I was actually shocked about
because like I thought we'd have like a
few people at the beginning and then
we'd also do it yeah when I got like ten
tweets in the space of one hour then
what pictures of YouTube and some of
them were picked just tweets like West
fast that's why yeah where are you
nobody asked about Rob everyone wanted a
white pal yeah Robbie okay there buddy
oh dude man you guys are about New York
Comic Con man I mean are you booking
hotel no I'm surfing rented see anything
good on reddit what's that what's the
haps on reddit that somebody managed to
remove a fence in front of the Lions
face so anyway Saturday then we all just
kind of wandered around met a lot of
other great people I think the funniest
one of the tens was I got stopped
walking between a bunch of stuff and
then like a little group formed around
and I'm like this is not a good spot for
this it's like that bit in the movie
where the bikers they keep driving
around you so you can't leave what
well the funniest thing I found was no
one recognized me in general like I
didn't get anybody going your Benny
unless I spoke right like we're walking
no one would see my face and I would say
something and now and then I'd get like
people go on economic story and I'm like
hey so ya know then Saturday we did a
comiXology thing which I would have
invited you to sell but I didn't realize
that it was like an open thing it was
for comixology podcast oh yeah so but it
was another free drinks thing and Jason
even wanted me there because we're
talking about doing a collaboration
later
so I mean cool stuff happening there but
the funniest thing ever so they they had
a free drinks of their podcasting
they did the podcast for five minutes
and then they showed it down and
everyone's doing
I'm like what's this maybe it's just
maybe they were just gonna like they
were doing a regular show and they're
gonna like edit in a segment where
they're like we're in New York comic-con
nothing happens
all right weird we got a we were hooked
up with a with tickets to go see
Hollywood babble-on with Kevin Smith and
Ralph Garman we went to go see that live
which was awesome and then they brought
us into the green room we got to meet
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman that was
pretty sweet tell me about that now I
hate it that happened and but man
Betty's love is as caustic as his hate
isn't it I know right it's like yeah I'm
so great Oh every time I hear the name
Kevin Smith my mind just goes that scene
in king of the Nerds there's this girl
crying on a bed going and my mind just
goes there every time that's so funny
yeah yeah I remember that that's for
that's like the nerd equivalent of it's
a [ __ ] walk off we didn't even
meet up Sunday no it's Showalter's
well like we we came in tiffany sister
was visiting and we and she had to take
a bus which was at Port Authority so
we're like might as well go will be
important the party you mean you didn't
film a video at the historic Port
Authority you didn't have comic pop
visit comic a lot of visits this
disgusting bus you see that's the
difference between you and me man I
would have made that video here's the
thing here's the thing about like comic
pop Andy like the disposable video we
did it already
like like you you you know you if you
love comic pop and this is not a
promotion for me or anything but if you
love our channel you've watched over you
save your watch every video there's four
years of a reality show of me and the
gang hanging out you'll never see but
most of them are like the gang goes to
the Port Authority the gang goes to an
abandoned fairytale Park the gang goes
to a candy store goes to the beach like
if that is not something you want to
watch then he watched it all when he
found us for the first time and he's
like take that crap dad say that I see
now I want to see buddy's side no when I
first found sallows playing Dark Souls
and I just had his channel on
playthrough eventually you get to the
old stuff he's hearing Christmas
specials he's like why is Santa Claus
hanging out with these guys
cartoon leprechauns and then like yeah
and he's like you okay what happened so
what were you trying to do and then
where did comic books come in like yeah
exactly so no we don't do the Port
Authority videos anymore well so anyway
yeah Sunday I don't know I went there
and just got a bunch of signatures I got
Joshua Williams InDesign birthright and
stuff like that Leo was there yeah damn
it nobody is booth that sucks ass where
was he was he nor say as a featured
signer
yeah so I show it up there and there's
like three other people they're getting
birthright sign I got my signed I asked
him he said afford it over to Skybound
and that was it like that's right II
meant sub didn't yeah I met job we hung
out that was cool I meant I hung out I
mean talk for five minutes that was it
but I count that I feel it's a wonderful
man Jim's up he teaches art here in
Toronto one of my best friends from high
school is actually a student of his
where he teaches our that's awesome no
we got the we also got one of those Jim
sub was handing out if you mentioned
wayward he would give you a little like
house of the clan yo-yo Keisler a little
low yeah yo guys layer like sticker that
was like you're the back your back okay
so he would get if you mentioned wayward
he'd be like oh well then you get to be
a yokai Slayer here's your sticker and
it would go it was it looked like a
little like banner flag like from Minas
cool and adhered to the back of your
badge so you know it was really cool we
met him and talked to him a little bit
we also got to meet the lovely and
talented marguerite bennett who is
incredible to meet in person but also
who's so cute because like she had the
she had the issue of that every writer
at a comic-con has which is i wrote the
book i cannot give you a sketch I don't
have prints for sale how about some
candy
so like her booth head ah and her booth
looked like a little like it looked like
a picnic where it was like some flowers
and some candy
ah and it was like I got her card and
her heart is just her name and her
Twitter handle like do I need like I
follow you on to it already I guess
that's it all right cool
yeah not to toot my own horn I'm sure
I've mentioned this before I was
actually one of the first people to
interview Margaery Bennett when I asked
her for an interview she's like why do
you want to talk to me like because you
wrote a Batman annual that's amazing and
you're going places that's why I want to
talk to you yeah and she certainly is
man she's awesome I got to show this to
Foust year ago if you if you freeze the
camera right here you can pinpoint the
moment those heartbreaks and half yes I
got another book Bob way words
completely signed by him to give out on
the channel if you just want it
steadfast no you're fine she gave it
away
well no it just it just says it's just
like a generic signature but it's just
if you're gonna give it away it's kind
of an [ __ ] things need to do if I'm
just like hey yeah thank you right
especially now that you've built it up
it would be just like yes give it to me
screw your fans yeah sure the reading
the chat I'm taking that what UK ones
yeah everyone in the chat you decide
just Foust get it or do I give it away
right okay really quick story we were at
New York comic-con Todd McFarlane had
had his Todd McFarlane Toys booth he was
doing signings he they were giving out
wristbands so that you can actually get
your signature there was no way to like
just go up to him and we kept like
trying to catch up with him every time
we got there he was gone been from comic
pop his one of his first comic books
ever was Batman spawn nice or rather
spawn Batman drawn by Todd McFarlane
written by Frank Miller who was also
there which Tiffany almost slammed into
him while they were walking by Wow
but so we're at the end of the day it's
they're packing them up like Ben had
been hanging out there the until like
almost like like an hour or two and then
MacFarlane shows up he's packing is
getting out of there and there's a
couple people who were like waiting in
the wings to like spring a book at him
mm-hm which is not gonna fly
McFarland's done this too many times a
dude knows his stuff and but but bid
just goes hey Todd and MacFarlane turns
because nobody's called him that and he
goes thank you so much for writing water
for drawing one of my favorite books and
holds up spawn Batman and refine looks
at him like you had and then he gives
him this total just like shit-eating
grin where he's like and then he reaches
over it he's like give me your hand and
gives him one of those like you're okay
in my book handshakes it's that look
that said I can't believe you brought
that to a Comic Con but also I'm kind of
impressed you did and then and had that
experience like no no it's better than a
signature that's a real moment now at
any point during this do Todd McFarlane
gets sued in between from walking back
Neil Gaiman came and just slapped him
and then like $20,000 fell out of his
ear now that's what I want the grudge
match of the century friggin Neil game
and MacFarlane in a steely cage one
night only those those don't happen as
often as they used to you at Frank Cho
and Robby Rodriguez like right across
from each other and neither of them
freaked out so that was interesting the
guy who draws spider-gwen apparently had
a real problem with Frank Chows
depiction of his fighter quit Frank show
has been apparently making in his career
to draw insulted him on variant covers
non-stop you know the socks show talking
about that Canadians will now add the
song but yeah I don't know what that
means
I assume it's you know some kind of show
it does a Canadian yeah doesn't it and
the sock is a comedy puppet not on like
tribes the insult comic dog he was on
our MuchMusic which was like your MTV
and now he has a web show
first off both chats say give it to
Foust it'll probably be more than giving
it to a random fan I agree give it a
fence okay Chad is spoken
I don't worry it was me I picked it up
to do it so it wasn't even like Jim's up
handed to me a hand to a fan I said I'm
willing to give this away yeah so it's
going too fast now and Bennie is there
any other story so we can talk about the
comics before yeah I'm good now if
anything comes up of course like since
there's you know it's the Wild West here
we can always bring it up in another
show I guess since we're talking
conventions it's London Comic Con next
week and I'm gonna be there oh I might
be there too really apparently I've got
like an offer to head out there I just
got a workout flying out there and it's
kind of sick so I'm trying to figure out
if I want to do it okay I'm 100% serious
I might be at the London Comicon that's
a heck of a plane ride I go overseas
like three times a year so it's not even
that big of a deal yeah and plus the
trip to London is well he'll hit well
he'll be here that's the point there
though I get a hug from Foust okay yeah
okay I mean if you can find me I'm gonna
be in cosplay Belgian consulate are you
fast are you
fat Sal likes personal space and I know
this so every time I see Sal I always
like weird about him I was like bring it
in oh yeah
I know you like giving hugs I just you
know I don't want to get tackled like a
linebacker you're very intense okay
so let's discuss the books there's only
three that matter this week the other
two are pre obviously previews of what's
coming so we're not gonna discuss that
similar issues well those books will
come out so it doesn't matter tied into
the comic book tied it to the game so
that doesn't matter either so let's
start off the top with Rob's favorites
that's rise of a quiet the book being
led up to by superior Iron Man
invincible Iron Man I don't know yes we
know what's being led up to my superior
I a man for a couple reasons one because
Pepper Potts isn't there in two because
Tony Stark refers to his armor is having
a biological and basically the same kind
of armor that he had the extremest 3.0
armor from superior Iron Man wasn't his
armor basically Bionic friggin got it so
once were it was Treme's it was a simian
in in superior Iron Man yet or variant
like it like it was a combination of his
extremist technology in assembly yeah
it's why would you drop that that was
good TAC I'd want to keep his exact
wording was it scares people
scary I liked the art there's one
there's a bomb in that book a bomb that
like is either
there's no way to throw away this is
been disses mic drop event implication
at the end or are we talking about the
beginning like the flirtation in in the
flirtatious conversation Bendis drops a
bomb connect this point forward we're
gonna be discussing Amazing Spiderman
Doctor Strange and invincible Iron Man
right there will be spoilers because
we're going to be discussing them they
came out last week if you don't want
spoilers thank you guys for watching
we're gonna spend in the next probably
fifteen to thirty minutes discussing
these three issues that's right so thank
you for joining us if you just wanted to
hear the contour ease we'll be back next
week if you don't mind spoilers stick
around okay go dude okay so the scene in
question is Tony Stark talking to an
equally intelligent person there he's
trying to bang her and there and he's
asking her for like what what high-tech
crazy secrets she is sitting on being a
genius and a futurist what's she sitting
on what's the bombshell she's got in her
back pocket and they and she basically
reveals that she can cure mutants
without hurting them without hurting
them she can literally cure mutation she
added the plot of x-men through and the
whole the whole kicker of that is that's
never happened before like no one's ever
you know what
is that's gonna be their excuses to help
he can shift him over and he was because
I got here here's my crazy theory
crafting on this one yeah they are going
to start curing mutants if you can't be
cured then you've been an inhuman the
whole time boy you go over to the new
planet mutant I think that's I think
that the the fact that I think they're
gonna I think obviously someone's gonna
steal it or the government's gonna
procure it or whatever but the point is
somebody bad is gonna get the or she's
gonna do it but someone evil or someone
malicious or someone with good
intentions who will take away mutant
powers it makes them a bad person
yeah is going to use this to make people
start to to force mutants to lose their
powers which will force mutants to leave
the planet which will lead into mutants
going away well that's what benda said
like during the conversation that Tony
Sartre was having with her he was like
you shouldn't keep that in your head
because like a psychic will find it
right they will take it out of your head
and they will use it and they will you
know for bad things
there are psychics there are thieves
there are psychic feed yes Stark has
mind wiped himself at least twice yeah
definitely has tech in his basement or
garage that can do that for her all this
big inert garage this is more theories
well but how about the fact that Tony
Stark now once again I think this is
like the 80th time wants to make things
right incorrect everything that it was
called Civil War - he's doing the same
damn thing apparently yeah like for me I
feel like that revelation is I don't
know ultimate end hasn't ended yet which
is hilarious but ultimate end for me and
then I'll see you'll see why I'm say
going into that but like ultimate end
for me as Ben disses like frustrated
angry response to like how come Jonathan
Hickman gets to rewrite the Marvel
continuity I'm the architect here and so
the Marvel Universe won't get rebooted
until I say it's rebooted that's why
ultimate end is so friggin not connected
and convoluted and I feel like this
mutant thing is Ben is his way of being
like okay we're getting back to basics
you're Bendis is back and we're gonna
from the apple cart here with the mutant
cure I listen I know that no one likes
my x-men but I will change the x-men
regardless of what they want to say we
all know they're trying to shuffle the
x-men away because of Fox now they were
able to do with Fantastic Four because
no one I mean what does it say as much
as ever people do like the Fantastic
Four no one cared about the book well
and the movies don'ts don't don't make
money so get rid of right and that's and
that's why they got rid of them but the
problem with the x-men is like what the
initial announcement of all new outlet
or Marvel I think had two of them but
because they're popular there's now five
again the problem is like Marvel Comics
sees the money Marvel Entertainment sees
like get rid of them we can't have the
night neither the fame of the TV and
movie studios can't get along is really
frustrating like so and of course
there's no way the TV shows and the
movies now there's talks about them not
linking up anymore the other frustrating
part is Marvel Entertainment the people
that do the TV shows in the movies are
now no longer under Marvel Studios there
under Disney Studios
although the TV should the TV is yeah TV
is still under these Marvel Studios the
movies can be direct it can go direct to
disc omit the annoying thing for me is
the comics have been around for longer
why are you letting the comics which
have survived the test of time already
be affected by the TV shows which let's
be honest and the movies which let's be
honest they're good but in 50 years time
we aren't gonna be talking about them no
no no the whole reason for that is
because Iron Man is a perfect example
like people people go and like bin mrs.
Iron Man all right invincible I'm at
number one is Marvel Cinematic Universe
Tony Stark and that's why because when
people say Tony Stark I know him he was
in the movies like we'd go to the comic
book store and they buy a comic they
want to see like robber dad want to see
that guy in a comic book and that's
basically a douchey good guy so that's
what they want to see they don't want to
see superior they don't want to see him
try to amend for civil war they want to
see a douchey good guy they weren't
rusev yesterday you
was gonna do the right thing but he may
try to sleep with this girl or have an
underhanded remark for this or you know
and that's been frustrating for me
because before the movies I could read
Iron Man but ever since then every Iron
Man story to me is just read as Tony
Stark
you know for a smart guy he's quite done
although okay I do want to make one job
for a first off I do I want to talk
about that one joke and I was like what
the ending of an Iron Man so we can move
on to the other one what
who else loved the joke about Thor
classic and a sense of humor right there
loading down this is like yeah wise away
yeah no like I mentioned in my video I
was like I was like business is kind of
returning Iron Man you know to his roots
whatever I was like but he still keeps
the funny stuff yeah my question soon
the eight month gap hey what happened to
Tina bomb ination I kind of liked him
hanging out I like the idea of Tony
having like a little son Pepper Potts is
now yes okay here's here's like Bendis
this is why uh-huh this is why you're so
confusing me um in an interview business
was like we're gonna see Pepper Potts
come back and we're gonna see happy
Hogan come back that's my knowledge
happy Hogan died alive new rules this
reboot isn't so much a reboot we've
established that we've all talked about
that no way but but it is giving them
the rights to do what they want with now
the joke I had with Rob and if you
follow us on Twitter you solace joking
about the whole superior Iron Man thing
yesterday is spider-man's going to be
answered in invincible Iron Man but it's
not really leaning into that like
there's literally a gap where he's now
good guy again
and we just don't have Pepper Potts here
no it's like that's why Matt doesn't say
it doesn't start off with like last time
a superior Iron Man like it yeah yeah
and I I got a feeling we're gonna get
our answers in the same manner that
we're gonna get the answer to the store
what Nick Fury said to Thor you're like
they're just going to say in an
offhanded panel and someone because
because every comic so bad somebody's
gonna fill me in later oh did you miss
that
I mean I mean I guess a lot can happen
in an eight you know eight month stretch
of time which I guess is one everything
starting up but they don't open the new
comics by saying hey eight months after
the end of Secret Wars well here was my
thought on that like my thought was and
I'm kind of with betting on this like I
think that Secret Wars were supposed to
be like a brand new cut everything you
know cat supposed to be a crisis but
they kind of backed out and so what
happened was once they were like okay
we're not gonna cancel everything out
we're just gonna kind of continue on and
we're gonna use Secret Wars to get rid
of the stuff we don't want yeah that
when Secret Wars started getting delayed
they were like well we gotta do
something like eight months and there
was just like a huge you know Marvel
wide thing every single title has to
start eight months after sticker Wars
that way they can come back and pretty
much write anything they want to yeah
but still like and my favorite I have to
say my favorite thing about this a month
gap is someone in the comments the other
day it was saying yeah but DC has never
done a time-skip like this it's cold one
year later and there was a whole series
called 52 that explained what happened
in between all the shows are doing and
now the flash starts like six months in
when they had time runs out you know and
it was suddenly you know the Avengers
and New Avengers jumped eight months
into the future you had the solo titles
that were covering that eight month
period like everyone know what captain
Merrick was doing you know during that
eight month period like all you had to
do is recap remember you know read
Rogers comics and and that's we're gonna
what they're gonna do here like I can
almost guarantee they're gonna come back
and they're probably gonna do you know
the DCE or one thing where they're gonna
say but I guess your zero your thing
we're they're gonna shave like a whole
line of comics that's gonna go on for a
month or two months or three months or
something like that you know eight
months ago or they had last days of they
need eight months of to be nothing okay
well because I do want to discuss this
the thing that they've been saying since
the dawn of all-new all-different marvel
coming out in October is go ahead and
read it
nothing will be spoiled for Secret Wars
oh good
the last page of invincible Iron Man
imagine I'd if it poured okay that's
what I didn't get you know because like
I was going through the read to like the
Marvel subreddit if they were like so
many questions people were like you know
can I just pick out all-new
all-different marvel do I need to read
anything before sycamores like no I was
like either that's being written by
comic book writers or by the horrible
people secretaries or something like
that or the people there don't know what
they're talking about because invincible
Iron Man spoils the hell out of still
not as bad as spider-man I mean try
gonna help me try and hop into new
spider-man and I was trying to stupid
thing over here uh but the big panel
revealed that yes it's a read then right
I didn't miss the one thing right there
no okay we've already announced it gonna
be spoilers doctor dude last panel the
Iron Man shows Doctor Doom in a suit
perfectly fine yeah
somebody somebody on my channel was like
he probably went through the siege
perilous I'm like you know what at this
point probably whatever that is trade
was that the thing he got to keep after
being God would say oh I'm defeated but
I'm keeping the face though yeah maybe
maybe it's a younger clone body and he
downloaded his personality into it and
pretend to be a son and now it's like
that's what happened in the eighth this
is kind of familiar that story you just
told where have I heard that else yeah
well they just had a crisis so that's
our invincible Iron Man opinions reviews
everyone here I mean I I say get it I
loved it oh yeah it was well-written if
you don't mind having like I mean I'd
what I made my video I was like by the
way there will probably be spoilers for
Secret Wars so if you don't mind and see
if you're not even reading Secret Wars
that you don't care like I keep saying
enjoy invincible Iron Man now for the
first two arcs until ventus gets bored
and starts working on other projects be
a girl the comments are we all read the
books and Jason read Secret Wars and
then he revealed it all in our video
that we put out for it like here's what
happened blah blah you should get it
Baba
I was a my finger in it
no I don't even care like that's all you
gave me all the bits I needed for that
one yeah right
so Manas before we talk about Doctor
Strange you talk about Avengers zero it
was a was it the same thing as the free
comic book day book um okay so my shoot
with Avengers number zero and I just
need to write about this is there's a
part because they go through exploiting
that well like all the different new
I'll just teams you can read about right
now and there's part where they got the
New Avengers which has Billy Teddy
Squirrel Girl and a bunch of characters
they don't care about an Avengers idea
mechanics yes yeah my issue of that the
preview that they showed and I hope the
whole series enlike this where the
hell's the fun you had like two of the
characters in the young that are from
The Young Avengers and Squirrel Girl
where's the fun yeah that should not
that that should be a whimsical fun book
I think spider-man's on that team too it
should be just like a jokey wisecracking
spider-man spider-man is on the uncanny
event onion right now like New Avengers
like mom was gonna cancel the hell but
here's the thing with New Avengers
though it's a big holdover from seekers
cuz the villain and that is the maker
who started a new team called whisper so
ultimate Reed Richards is now in the
main universe Maslin and has the secret
war is established him as being the dark
Reed down like right I mean I think
about thirty pulls off the mast we see
the damage done and all that other crap
so we do is there yeah which is never
like big reveal
oh yes you've been reading you know
because we haven't seen much of Reed in
anything for this all-new all-different
I wonder is maker just going to be read
now
well I mean like yeah we don't know I
don't know I think they're gonna keep
the the the 616 read under their hats
until Secret Wars is over and like
either he's gonna come back eventually
but I guarantee you something happens
where he's gone same thing with sue I
don't think I've seen her in anything we
wouldn't read I think are gone from
something yeah kids do we haven't seen
the kids in anything the kids either but
we do have been grooming
maturity value should put Franklin and
valaria on the next men team or
something just because just missus or
create a new new power pack team yeah
that's what we mean yeah we need the
white mane kids to come back and go to
dr. strange next cuz I'm first off loved
that that had to be the best book this
week it's incredible I loved I loved it
but the layout really I could not stop
thinking of Sam I know which are the
whole time I was reading it I was like
this just feels a little bit too Neil
Gaiman inspired like so likely going to
bring I mean like who doesn't want a
Neil Gaiman Doctor Strange book yeah but
if I want it done by Neil Gaiman is not
going to give me a write in a duck
stream i-i-i-i I enjoyed the book but I
think I liked it a little less than the
lesser than the rest of you for a Jason
arrant book it was surprisingly
unchastened irony we're just about it a
lot of you I liked about it cuz I've
always looked at dr. strange as being
like the all powerful sorcerer supreme
we go get him when there's a problem and
we're never gonna write a book about him
so you never get to know more about this
guy I love like the first issue we
didn't go into any of that
they just ignored that whole thing and
there were just like here's what he does
the great part for my favorite scene was
going into the bar like you like it's a
cool idea that dr. strange hangs out
with Scarlet Witch in brother voodoo and
all these guys just shaman that I liked
the opening page reveal that shows you
the Ditko Stanley usual panels from the
actual first Doctor Strange it is but as
if to say like that nothing changed yeah
like if you read this if you've been
reading Doctor Strange since 1967 or
whatever you like it's the same freakin
character and that's like for me I'm
like good like because I'm because
there's also gonna be another book
called Spidey which is I'm sure gonna
repconn
everything about his origin so that he's
young and hip and newer and and looks
like the new actor from the new movies
well I guarantee you that suit on the
cover of Spidey is gonna be in the
movies it's too specific but anyway I
feel like but I love that that page
because it was just like it
it's the same doctor strange cool gosh
Lazard I liked I liked to Aaron's
dialogue I liked that I liked how he
subdued the sandworm chick that every
crazy person you've ever met Mike just
beasts might be a wizard you're a wizard
Harry yeah you just normally like oh
what a crazy guy yeah I love that idea
that's that's a fun element that I like
to see in fiction where it's like the
world with it like the world below the
surface of another world and like the
things that you take for granted are
actually things going on like I think
that's really cool surprised I launched
in teen 2 which got me at points he's
walk-in and talkin I'm like is he gonna
light a smoke now cuz that's the only
thing he's missing right now and why
Larry Constantine vibe the way that the
way that the walk stands everything was
like that hands in the pockets slouched
over I'm glad I'm not crazy I'm gonna
especially with the way constant he's
being written right now it looked almost
like identical what I liked about this
though was um like how they described it
I was so so prepared for like this dark
book that's like yeah this is good but I
want to die
it's actually kind of fun yes yeah it's
not it's not melancholy and I know the
set up at the end with like wizard
hunters and stuff that's cool that's
cool
I'm surprised yeah we'll see here's a
cool thing I liked most about Doctor
Strange is they they didn't treat the
readers like idiots they weren't like oh
hey guys by the way like here's the
origin story of dr. strange like he was
a surgeon who was an [ __ ] he got into
a car wreck and he went he was dr. house
m.d. you know like we didn't we didn't
need the ordinary like people know who
doctor doctor Strange's and if they
don't you could literally just tell them
during the credits yeah and that's the
movie that's a really cool thing about
it like I do like that idea
one I like immediately went off the bad
Jason Aaron was like other dimensions
what one of the things that I really
liked who was it took away like it
removed the element of him like
physically going to other dimensions and
was like he's really just performing a
seance basic
this kid yeah like that I think was a
really cool thing because you know it's
like you're making kissy faces you're
making kissy faces I said Eric it's done
I like the lake I like the pacing you
know I like the way it's ready you know
because Jason arrant set the stage and
made it's simple like hey some bad
stuffs happening and I think I'll be
doing my most likely but you know he's
gonna be in the movie so of course it's
gonna dude was in Marvel vs. Capcom ooh
and I mean I mean heck in the ant-man
comic they brought back what's-his-face
evil Industrials even though he'd been
dead since the original ant-man story
they brought him back because he was
gonna be in the movie so yes read dude
yeah Darren cross he's dices the origin
he ever came back all right so let's
talk about the last one then by your man
amazing spider-man there's gonna be a
book called spider-man the miles miles
so here was a kicker like when I made my
video on Amazing Spiderman I was like
okay first things first this is an
example of how all-new all-different
marvel is not that all you want to know
what's going on a spider-man like you're
gonna have to read comics from like two
years ago they're gonna have to read
everything slot every road cuz slot pays
off everything he's ever done hey here's
how Rison labs in max mode Al and
everybody go through that like I had to
go through all of it like from the
launch of horizon labs through superior
spider-man I kind of touched on
spider-verse almost like in this spot
ever happened you know and then you know
jumped into like going into the story
but that's even the cliffhanger ending
on that one was like oh yeah
I saw that comment like what are they
gonna do that's big oh they got a
mention doc ock again
well like the once the living brain was
brought in in the beginning of support
of the arc for spear spider-man I'm like
oh yeah well he's gonna be the the
linchpin like which would you totally
got to give slot crate or it's like
maybe you wrote so many backdoors into
this so you could get em superior if you
add - yeah well you know I'll be honest
- like it wasn't really even until like
I finished amazing spider-man number one
and Doctor Octopus was revealed to be
you know have like a copy of his brain
and the looming rain that when I was
going back and looking at superior iron
or superior spider-man I was like why
didn't I think of that before
it's true it's like the most obvious
thing because the Bullock's octobot
threw you off is what it was that was
the red herring that was that was the
Kansas City shuffle that was getting
everybody looking over here when the
real stuff was happening over here yeah
like all of these throw bags just proved
like and people's reactions to it just
prove what we've been saying all along
which was we had we were kind of like -
in terms of where we stood with Secret
Wars yeah yep entirely everything no I
don't I think that this literally was
like because some of the people we've
spoken to have said they had other plans
and I think Marvel jumped on board we're
gonna do it we're gonna find the reboot
we've never done it and just started
everybody get up
yeah they planned it out they were like
they got cold feet at the last second
yeah they were there at the altar but
then they runaway bride at it right at
least Oh like don't keep saying yeah
yeah yeah gonna be yeah for sure they
did and Presley say it's from the
beginning this is not a reboot yeah he
said it's not a reboot but it kind of is
like there's no there's nothing about
all-new Altima
all right Madame Madame masque was a
character from 1969
all right she's been around for decades
and she's gonna be on TV so we need to
bring her back and make her a big
character again advanced idea mechanics
been around for decades amazing
spider-man
been around forever like you got to read
stuff before Secret Wars Doctor Strange
you can read stuff before secret war so
know what as characters about The
Ultimates blue Marvel Adam Brashear is
before secret war like all that stuff is
all before so you're gonna need to in
order to get to know who they everything
before Secret Wars is still relevant
what was the point in destroying six one
six you could have literally just moved
the ultimate Universal but because yes
it was almost like they wanted to just
kill Ultimate Universe again well hey
guys we gotta sell those trades so if
you want to know what's happening at
all-new all-different go read be all old
all you know maybe that was a part of it
there we're worried about trade sales
and everyone's saying it's a reboot you
don't have to read the old stuff and all
that other crap yeah what they do in the
movie to do I say didn't that hurt them
the loss of cuz only the classic sold at
that point Killing Joke and all i crap
well Batman and Green Lantern cuz they
basically got to keep going but that's a
whole other topic but no so I mean
amazing spider-man because they have
anxious about what happens in it is
basically does pick up exactly where it
left off at the end of the soup of
spider-man horizon was just our Parker
industries industries were destroyed and
he was like how are we gonna keep going
and now Parker Industries is worldwide
David meant that a lot of Technology
Peter Internet's Peter Parker's now in
the limelight while he's got like other
people pretending to be spider-man yes
he's got a whole crew of backup
spider-man like Hobie Brown and I assume
spider-man 29 as I look I got a job how
would you like to dress up like me so I
can be everywhere at once
yes well yeah well they even made a
whole big stink about he's underpaying
himself so he'll still be poor Peter
Parker yeah but he owns all of his she's
still relatable everybody it's fine he's
not a multi gazillionaire he's still
just like you he's just not Tony Stark
yet guys he's a poor man's Tony Stark
but you know it's Pizza poppies can I
lose it in two years that's how they do
and I ask this in our review and I also
add mentioned this on the internet I was
like where's it May hmm and no reference
to work at all like not even like a hat
may would be proud nothing
we got Uncle Ben because there's an
Uncle Ben foundation but we got
and now a and I'm really hopeful and I
don't and I doubt this will happen but I
kind of want them if they're gonna
Spidey it up and blew it off it's all
the only everything's the same except
for spider-man's origin fold ultimate
Aunt May over the octogenarian that take
that took care of him forever because
I'm so sick of dead and dying at may I
would like to have relevant fun milf
Aunt May she's gonna be played by Marisa
Tomei so like cuz like I've I want
ultimate Aunt May and I kind of want
ultimate Jamison if the odd maids in the
movies get any younger it's gonna be
teen months my son is a spider boy yeah
the life of a teenage spider remember
spider-man's mom no it would but see one
thing I would like to see though like
continue on is the whole like on mage a
jonah jameson like we're bumpin uglies
thing that was his dad not not j jonah
was his dad she was with oh okay you
know it may marry to j jonah Jameson's
father well for the record though I mean
you guys liked amazing spine right I
loved the directional anyone with this I
enjoyed it I was really expecting it to
say I wouldn't you have you told me a
year ago that I would like the new this
first issue more than any of her New
Year vows I told you you were crazy
right renew your vows was like this
sloppy mess and this is actually paying
off things like I didn't like the the
characters that Dan Slott had created
for the series like max Modell and
horizon lassen I was really sad to see
where that wound up and I was really
glad to see what happened like the
payoff in this issue and I was like this
is really like that that was really nice
I was I enjoyed the carrot development I
was happy to see some of these
characters actually like doing well or
at least being being respected and
treated like you know Givens a story
yeah it's cool
i I love the fact they're bringing them
back like it
yes this could just be me but like I
read the spider-man book and like oh
people are happy I don't trust it never
trust happiness no but I also know that
like slot wants Peter Parker to succeed
that's the difference is that like most
writers like oh boy a person I can kick
like like Stegman or D Mateus or Mikkel
ie like just eat it like you're Bob Gale
it's like yeah this guy really sucks
doesn't everybody da dance lost the only
guy who was like yes dude could actually
probably outsmart Reed Richards if he if
he gave him a few minutes or you know
this guy actually invented web shooters
and he was friggin 15 or nice dude
actually knows his stuff and he's been
through the wringer more than like the
thing so like might want to give him
kind of a pass like this dude knows his
history he knows the character and above
all else he loves this character yeah
and he doesn't love him like he thought
he thinks spider-man's a cool looking
drawing like he really wants Peter
Parker to succeed it's why cuz he could
have easily been like Parker Disney's it
was a cool idea that like obviously was
never gonna work out it falling to the
ground is typical Parker luck move the
hell on and get us back to kicking Peter
Parker down the road he's like but he
but instead he's like let's do something
different let's let's Surprise them by
making it actually succeed let me win a
little now that being said it will be
destroyed of course
like burger disease will be will
probably be absorbed into Stark
Industries actually wouldn't it be
interesting to see PETA destroying
Parker industries like his I'm voice cuz
he's whole he's horrible like he's he is
his responsibility is his downfall right
now it's gonna happen Parker that's
gonna turn into Skynet and basically and
he's gonna have to destroy they're
already setting the stage for that like
I mean you already had you
no technology install like yes the
Johnny Jeffrey whatever name is like no
that was written you like working for
black hat and that was and all right
look the supporting cast is cool you
know like seeing and seeing all those
characters come together and singing how
they're being developed and so on and so
forth you know that's a really cool
concept the problem that I have with the
story is that it felt like at the end of
the day a typical pilot a spider-man
story hey here's this guy who's really
popular and let's have him fight like a
row group of some small-time terrorists
that one is the zodiac Lords the zodiac
you know and it's like really you know
that's what he is if you don't like if
you didn't like spider-man
25 years ago guess what yes still don't
like but you know what we do well his
supporting cast is cool but as villains
are garbage whose villains are better
what like who has a better rogues
gallery what superhero besides Batman
has a more identifiable and better
rogues gallery
hardly like I love developed rogues
gallery sure spider-man has that I mean
Kraven is a great character like we know
who Kraven is not Kraven no Craven was a
great because like there's great
characters in Spiderman Scott knew the
problem is at the end of the day it's a
top-tier character in Marvel Comics just
kind of like fighting what amounts to
muggers yes the lactis he wouldn't be
spider-man anymore interesting because
we know how like I know I was there's no
there's no suspense here it's like oh my
god like are they gonna crash Parker
Industries are they gonna use this
technology to destroy his company no of
course not it's encrypted he's like
we've got 12 hours until they do my
encryption okay well we know what's
gonna happen but then the last time that
they did something big out there was
spider-man that I can recall because I'm
no huge spider-man reader was spider-man
and the x-men and
was hilarious but I didn't sell well no
I mean like you want a cosmic crash like
spider-man book you got spider-verse
when they save the multiverse or
something got 2099 where he's traveling
through time and space doing whatever
you got like I mean spider-man they're
doing both and I foresee amazing going
in the direction of more out there
storylines
because we have like five other
Spiderman books following Peter Parker
do you want to see if you wanna see
spider-man like going big time and not
like the book called big time but a
Spider Man like dealing with like
next-level threats there's a story from
like the 90s called like where it's one
of the spider-man books where he fights
Thanos and it's not infighting it's like
he dies and it's any meets Thanos cuz
Thanos is being a death at the time and
like you did of 40 and and it's the it's
it's a typical spider-man story but he's
still dealing with feyo's and it's what
happens when that hat like when
spider-man faces against like the only
thing that I can think of that Rob might
enjoy is when Spiderman foot Fire Lord
and defeated him and problem is the
problem is Rob is that spider-man is not
yet he's not like the Avengers
spider-man is like on the level of like
daredevil
he just says Frank and webs you know I
get they're not gonna see daredevil
fighting blackest samite all spider-man
number 1 which says ok Peter Parker is
no longer like just a street-level crime
fighter like he's don't like the guy
fighting on the street like he owns a
corporation he's a higher-up he's part
of this like his like his position in
the hierarchy of you know society on the
planet Earth an amazing spider-man
number one is a reflection of his
position in the ranks of Marvel comic
characters like he's right up there at
the top now and so the idea here is and
after it's all said and done like he's
spider-man and he's Peter Parker he owns
partner industries he's got all this
money and all this technology and stuff
like he's gonna go fight thugs and it's
like really well for him now yeah it
seems like lazy storytelling because
instead
right riveting stories where he's
dealing with corporate espionage how do
you know how do you know we were doing
that they are against him and he's come
yeah yeah now that that's the kind of
thing that's the thing you wanted but
you're basing an entire opinion of the
of the brand-new run host incident you
don't even know what's gonna happen how
do you know he's not gonna chase this
thing down at a turn that he's traveling
through the dimensions again and more
ones here you're like I hate this
because he's gonna fight thought mug a
thug errs in mugs and you don't have let
me very well be the case but the purpose
of a first issue is to real people in
yeah but you're trying to reel in
spider-man readers you're not trying to
really well I think they are trying to
reel in new people and that's why I was
like that's what he's Iron Man Spider
Man's bodyguard he owns a tower it's got
his name on it he's got big show in the
book like they lampshade the heck out of
that in the book going yeah but I'm a
really poor man's Tony along terms like
he's robbed about to be wrong again I'm
saying like to me is a non avid
spider-man reader I went into this and I
said there are elements of this story
that are amazing seeing Parker
industries being you know I guess kind
of trying to take it now taken out from
within like seeing members of his
company trying to take out Peter Parker
and replace Parker industries with their
own image is a cool concept you know but
once again the final conflict of the
story was give us your watch see this is
a fluid amounted to this will make this
is what makes me love about this whole
conversation is I'm in the same boat as
Rob but also the totally opposite end of
it because when I read a spider-man
story like I'm not an avid spider-man
reader but I want something like
spider-man and the x-men well I'm just
crying with laughter all time where I've
got like the most quotable line of the
year like in spider-man the x-men it was
honestly but I don't want to cure cancer
iodine assaults I want to make people
into dinosaurs
yeah I like Iran did that character was
surgery
the dinosaur man yeah Sauron the dasa
then no think about this number up and
here and here is just more proof that is
continuing on the way it was you want
more out there Adventures you enjoyed
spider-verse right to degree which is
funny because I hated spiders
spider-verse wise next level we are
technical only for issues from that I
agree I'm not saying it's impossible
what I'm saying is like we haven't even
also you've had since then is a is a
corporate espionage bad guy known as the
ghost that is all we've had so exactly
what you want is exactly what's happened
because Secret Wars put spider-man on
hold for six months yeah yeah so all's
we've had is what you wanted and now
we're going into the next arc we don't
know where it's gonna go the corporate
that's been announced person that was
black cat I'm pretty sure that's who
however that to be o-silk is working for
black cat like that's the basis of her
story and alchemax was trying to wreck
him too cuz alchemax didn't like what
was going on with them and it also
didn't Moulton made work for Alka make
sure it's a hey man what's up with
Ellen's brother so yes I'm just saying
like lizallen is now by no means do I
think Amazing Spiderman was a terribly
written story no but Launchpad there are
just elements of it that didn't appeal
to me yeah that's fair
well Rob I'm gonna leave it on this note
you're wrong the champion starts on the
big stuff like like there's gonna be a
huge dump next week yeah cuz the
champions wasn't horrible but it wasn't
I would surprised how much I ended up
liking contests of shavings it was just
goofy good-natured fun I would totally
read a book about the outlaw the black
British Punisher like
like The Hunger Games meets mortal
kombat yes certainly was and if you can
get on board with that goofiness then
I'm all for also I like stick is alive
now and hanging out with the my stars
just I had I'm Scott and Len was a dude
that was a cool like just like brew for
one second that was a cool review
when the moisture was like why do we
need here to have a like when we have
the original the man who we had the man
who taught him like we've got the
champion's is cool and next week
tomorrow we got a whole bunch more books
go now so it's gonna be awesome we have
stuff to talk about again guys so based
upon the sundial in Rob's house because
like that will give me nightmares now
what is it after the Joker's in Gotham
was awesome again didn't watch the new
episode last night I know I know it's
penguin folks I was gonna watch before I
hopped on here I if we had your Paul
Reubens is gonna play penguins - no boss
currently but none of that matters so
anyway thank you we are here every
Tuesday at six not six
yeah Oh on our twitch channel twitch.tv
backslash eligible monster if you're
watching this over my channel this is
more of a sneak preview of what we do
over there sometimes I stream this over
here sometimes I don't that's what
happens and if you want to watch it post
it will be up on iTunes and on Rob's
channel which is comics explained thank
you guys so much for joining us is there
any parting notes we need to say my
brains about to explode with sickness so
I just kind of want to always remember
guys if there's anything that my
discussions on spider-man have taught
you is that unless you agree with the
hive mind as you walk down that road of
life remember hitchhike it's faster
faster I can do that I can do that
alright thank you guys so much we will
see you next week right here
same bat-channel same spiderman time
that's right
all-new all-different all the same you
know we're gonna do we're all gonna
we're all gonna go to each other's house
extremely I'm gonna go to Foust house
he's gonna come here yeah but it'll do
the same weekly poll just different
locations exactly thank you guys